[Music]
hey guys welcome to the next episode of
collaborations
[Music]
the dogs got the barks out of the ways
dude and it's time to open up our laptop
i used to think it was a laptop
but it's laptop but i think a lot of
people did that and i know a guy who
still says laptop even though he's 37
and that's very bad to be that [ __ ]
guy
it's like the guy who says supposably
i learned it when i was in my teens
it's [ __ ] supposedly my mom told me
and i got pissed that she was right dude
here's the thing i don't like being
wrong
i don't like it
i
got honked at today because i didn't
think that
yeah i didn't move fast enough in the in
the traffic
so far i didn't move fast enough into
the traffic and um
a guy honked at me because i was looking
down at my phone and kristen says babe
and i said what and she said
nothing and i said
what and she said you know what and i
said because you think i needed to go
and she said yeah and i said i didn't i
was doing it fine
and she said then why did the guy honk
pissed
okay
got super pissed because yeah okay i
guess you're right then great so what
are we doing here so what we're still
going to the place or what
and we still went to the place we had a
great time dude so you can be wrong and
still have a great time and that's what
i wanted to make sure that you knew
that's what i wanted to do dude it's
time
for [ __ ] congratulations dude
um
and we're already [ __ ] two minutes in
when we're rip roaring dude you see the
shirt i got on what does it mean who
knows but here's the deal when a guy
comes up to me on the street
and says i have a free shirt for you
i wear it that night
okay
he came up to me i was in frigging lock
la canada which is armenian guy central
and armenian guy came up to me and he
said hey bro
as i was getting out of my car i said i
said oh what's up he said oh bro i'm a
big fan man i know you from the stuff
you were saying about armenians on your
podcast bro
and i said oh like the
don't touch my face [ __ ] and he was like
yeah bro i said that's how you
found out about me and he said yeah bro
that clip i guess it made the [ __ ]
rounds
i guess it made the rounds with [ __ ]
people with black hair dude
i guess it made rounds with the chain
wearers
with the mock turtle with the softest
[ __ ] mock turtleneck wearers dude
armenians were soft as [ __ ] mock
turtlenecks dude you'd be like where the
[ __ ] did you get that what's that made
out of it and they'd be like hey hey hey
i don't talk about i don't ask you about
your business right
and i was like no way dude i was like
that's awesome bro i was like i know
about armenians because i [ __ ] i'm
from here in la canada and like there's
so many armenians like some of my
[ __ ] good friends armenians and he
was like hell yeah bro and i was like
cool
and an armenian can't just leave it
there dude he goes like this
hey um i have an uh company it's an
armenian uh clothing brand
and i was like oh yeah and he was like
yeah he's like um
can i give you a shirt and i was like
[ __ ] yeah dude and i expected some janky
ass [ __ ] but he gave me this [ __ ] this
shit's comfy as [ __ ] dude hyasbora
hyaspora
uh
he told me what it meant and i forgot
already it's a play on diaspora which
probably could get me canceled if i'm
wearing something like this but [ __ ]
love that dude man
um
so he gave it to me and it's soft as
[ __ ] just shout out to my to my man i
forget his name at this point but that's
the company name of the shirt and i'm
wearing it and oops it makes the [ __ ]
pecs look all nice and oops it makes the
biceps [ __ ]
top allowed over the inside of my elbows
so oops on that and my triceps are just
hanging off like cliff from arizona
oops you know what i'm talking about
dude
so sorry about all that sorry my back's
all nice oops sorry we got tarps
covering rolling green zoops
sorry about all that
okay
and uh but that's what it is that's what
it is when you got a shirt that's butter
soft right armenians make soft as [ __ ]
mark turtlenecks
mock turtlenecks mock turtlenecks strong
with me
uh is it
mark turtlenecks no it's mock
turtlenecks so anyway dude
[ __ ] killing it and a nice little of
course you know he got it out of the
trunk of his bmw uh s armenian and it
was all good dude we make fun of
everybody on this podcast so don't come
after me i love armenians dude i [ __ ]
love armenians
straight up
um
so yeah man you know that's what
happened um
and uh he was like will you tag me and i
was like [ __ ] sure and i was like
dude i'm just gonna wear it bro you know
um
i slept you know what i did
last night
fell asleep
nothing crazy about that obviously you
fall asleep at night woke up six
uh a.m
nauseous city
okay woke up 6 a.m
felt like
there was
a country at war in my in my intestines
okay didn't understand it my stomach was
turning around i was like let's see if
we can get through this wasn't sure if i
could
waited around for about 30 minutes
so i couldn't get back to sleep because
i was nauseous city i was like should i
take tums or should i take a trip to
zany island
now
i took a trip to zane island because i
thought that would hit it i thought that
would hit my [ __ ]
and in 15 minutes i'd be out like a
[ __ ] light
like i like
and um
so i took a trip down i got in the canoe
and i used my back to scoop through down
to zany island that's what i did dude
i took a [ __ ]
i i got all aboard
zanussi island that's what i did okay
i got a table for two at zanzibar that's
what i did dude
that's what i did
i took 0.25 milligrams nothing
people out here taking [ __ ] two full
zany bars just to get through the day
took point two five to go to sleep
snothin
all right
hit me hard didn't need to take the
[ __ ] tums pass the [ __ ] out what
happens if you listen to this podcast
here's a quiz what happens to your boy
after he wakes up for about an hour and
then goes back to sleep in the morning
what happens to your boy even without
zany island
what happens to your boy your boy has
vicious dreams
your boy has dreamed so hard it's like
they plugged him into the matrix and now
this is his real life these dreams
now
that means if you take a trip to zanny
island
while you're doing some vicious dreaming
all bets are off i'm a [ __ ] uh like
i'm an eagle with person legs at this
point
in my real in my head you know what i
mean
like i have wings and i'm not in the
dream where i'm like
what's up with the [ __ ] wings i have
i don't normally have wings
i'm so deep in this dream i'm like
yeah
these are my wings i'm not even thinking
about them i just have wings like their
legs and a belt or something
you know
like that's how far down zany island i
am
and how far down deep deep into the
matrix of dreaming i am
so it's 10 15 and i don't know that
until later after i wake up but that's
what time it is just to let you know
when this next part happens
all right
now i'm deep in zany island i'm doing
some vicious dreaming because it's the
time i dream anyway but also i'm all
along xanthesee island
okay
i
am having a dream
now let me tell this story from
kristen's perspective because that's the
better way to tell the story i could
tell you about this dream but when
people think about their dreams they're
[ __ ] boring as [ __ ] right
when somebody walks up to you and you
know them a little bit or a lot it
doesn't matter or even not at all and
they say dude i gotta tell you about
this dream what do you do you go like
this oh for [ __ ] sake here we go in
your head but on the outside you say oh
what happened
and you're pissing yourself for not
being honest so now
you're pissed that you got to stand here
and listen to this [ __ ] boring
story slash dream this guy's saying and
you're also pissed off because that guy
made you be not honest
so this guy perpetrated two offenses in
one question
would you like to hear my dream
so i'm not going to tell you that
because this is a pockets goes out to a
lot of people and our listenership is
exploding
okay
you know how it goes
we'll move it up
youtube views they're fine
but the listenership
[Music]
so i wake up
so i wake up and i know i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be the man oh
[ __ ] whatever you know
and uh i will walk 500 miles
oh that song dude and i will walk 500
more just say you'll walk a thousand
miles dude okay
shorten up the song
i will walk 1000 miles and that's the
end of the song
anyway dude
was that by the pretenders
proclaimers same [ __ ] doesn't matter
we'll move it up
[Music]
so um
so now
i wake up and when i wake up i don't do
that wake up that you wake up
and you just kind of are like oh maybe
i'll get up you know what i mean
sometimes you wake up and you're like is
it time to get up or i'm not going to
open my eyes yet
i'm just going to chill and kind of like
ease into the wake up
it's like it's like the calisthenics or
the [ __ ] no the warm-up of the
wake-up where you're just like am i
awake yet
sometimes you do that and sometimes you
do
what i did
you wake up in the middle of a dream
and it's not just waking up in the
middle of the dream
the dream is hectic and violent and way
deep a few levels into the matrix
and you do this
okay
that was the first sound i heard when i
woke up and oops it was coming from me
i go whoa
okay
now kristen unbeknownst to me is already
awake
and she laughs and she says oh my god
honey are you okay
and i like start laughing because i know
why i made that sound and you don't and
she didn't at this point
so now i go from groggy and i'm still
groggy but all along the way i also am
excited to tell her why i woke up
because
it was quite possibly the funniest
moment
that has happened to me all year okay
this is why i woke up making that noise
i was in a dream
but i didn't know i was in a dream i
thought it was real life
and i was
in the lobby of the waiting room
which doesn't exist
for a movie that we were shooting
and a lobby where you're waiting to
shoot doesn't exist when you're doing a
movie you're just kind of waiting around
you're either at craft service or in
your trailer but there was a lobby it
had like an elevator in it and a
receptionist and [ __ ] and we were all
waiting to shoot a movie our parts
there was already an actor in there
shooting his part
and
in the waiting room there was me and
hugh jackman
and hugh jackman was dressed like a
knight okay he was in night armor
knight's armor but it was also like some
samurai japanese style kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what i'm talking about
like the last samurai but like [ __ ]
but he was hugh jackman not tom cruise
so there was a famous actor shooting me
and then also hugh jackman i don't
remember who the famous actor was as
soon as i woke up i forgot who it was
right
but i'm in the middle of this dream
and i'm dreaming now this is about
35 seconds before i wake up going
okay
so i say
so i'm with you jackman and the first
actor is done doing it done doing the
part right he he comes in and then it's
hugh jackman hugh jackman says i guess
it's more to now you know he's
australian and [ __ ] even though it
doesn't seem like he would be and i said
cool so he goes and he shoots his part
and then the dream kind of fast forwards
and hugh jackman's done and he comes
back out and he says
ah how's it going and i said hey man how
was it and he said ah good man it went
great and i said ah [ __ ] great man
come on dude really he said yeah it went
really well and i said oh come on
literally in the dream i said oh come on
hugh jackman okay
i say you're [ __ ] like this huge
action movie star and it sucks like i'm
like this guy and now it's my turn and i
gotta follow what you did it sucks and
he says ah my it'll be all right and i
was like nah it's not gonna be all right
i'm gonna look so bad and he goes like
this ah don't worry about it he starts
walking into the other room and i'm
following him and i'm doing this thing
where like i'm pretending to be upset
more upset than i am and he clocks it he
knows and he's going along with the bit
so now i'm in this dream and i got hugh
jackman doing bits with me and we both
know about it it's not like i can't read
the room i'm reading the room hugh
jackman's in the room and he gets my bit
and
he's in [ __ ] night slash japanese
armor gear
and i don't even know this is a dream
so i'm like this rocks okay
hugh jackman is like all right whatever
playing the part of the [ __ ] bit
where he's like all right my it's going
to be fun you're going to do all right
walks into the other room and he walks
through a doorway and in his night slash
japanese samurai outfit he goes to punch
a wall okay like as a joke he's like i
might ah you'd be fine right he goes a
bunch of wall and i'm sitting here like
nah man i can't do it i can't do it i
can't do it and as he goes to punch the
wall i link my arm into his arm and i
stop him from hitting the wall and i say
i can do it okay
now hugh jackman still
loaded in this bit right we're both
still meeting eye to eye in this bit
hugh jackman now is acting like he's
pissed at me as the bit he's like hey
mike what are you doing i was trying to
punch a wall and i was like oh yeah well
what [ __ ] that you know like you can't
do that and then he starts coming at me
going to tackle me pushing me
back against where the reception area is
of this waiting room that never has ever
existed on any movie set in the history
of the world okay so as he's pushing me
back i'm like falling backwards and [ __ ]
but it's all like we're hamming it up
because we're in the bit dude all right
and he's going to punch me and i
as i'm falling back reach back to grab
an imaginary knife okay
in the dream in the dream the knife is
imaginary i'm doing a bit in the dream
of grabbing this imaginary knife and i
say out loud as hugh jackman is tackling
me i go ah he grabs a knife and stabs it
in the back
and i [ __ ] go i put it over hugh
jackman's shoulder and i land it and i
sink that fake bit knife right into his
the back of his shoulder blade i say oh
he grabs the knife and stabs it in hugh
jackman's back
and then hugh jackman goes ah and then
he pushes back further right and then
i say on the other hand i say oh he
grabs an iron and smashes it over hugh
jackman's head oh and i say this out
loud and hugh jackman goes ah
and then i say
he grabs an orange because that's the
only thing that's left and he squeezes
over it squeezing it over the back of
his neck and i go
and i go whoa and that's when i woke up
i woke up
grunting
because i was saying out loud in my
dream
[Music]
grabs an orange because that's the only
thing that's left and squeezes it over
the back of his head
while hugh jackman was
tackling me
in night slash samurai gear
and i wake up and i go
and kristen says oh my god honey are you
okay
[Laughter]
like i don't know
in what sense
am i okay dude i was dying and then she
was like
and then she was like okay well and i'm
like dude
so she and then i looked over and she
was videotaping me talking about i had
no idea so i posted it to instagram so
you can go check it out my instagram or
you can just [ __ ]
send somebody this podcast but it was
the [ __ ] most like dude it was so
funny that like
i don't even know why i was having this
dream
because i was so [ __ ] far down
like
on zanussi island and taking a trip to
[ __ ]
uh you know what i mean and but it was
so ridiculous
and it was like this whole [ __ ] past
few years
it was like i got cut out of this
[ __ ] movie you [ __ ] cut out of
four movies it's like now that i'm in
this
situation where i'm in these movies
where i'm on the [ __ ] i'm in the
lobby and i'm just creating this idea of
oh how i can't be an action movie star
and hugh jackman is an action movie star
dude
it's hilarious
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] man
god i hate when my dogs [ __ ] bark huh
ah they were just barking through all
that [ __ ] story i don't think you
heard it but
oh my god
grabs an orange because it's the only
thing that's left and squeeze it
squeezes it over the back of your hugh
jackman's head
that's how my day started and i was
exhausted all day i don't know if it was
mainly from taking [ __ ] 0.25 of a
xanax or also maybe because i was like
working so hard in the dream to try and
best cue jackman not only physically but
with my bits
so hugh jackman if you ever hear that
dude
let's do that let's do that bit um
absolutely insane
hey when the [ __ ] is
kanye gonna release donda and maybe he
has by the time this podcast comes out
but
where's donda
okay
i don't i don't
you know what was cool when beyonce put
out her [ __ ] album and nobody knew it
was coming out and then it just came out
and everyone's like did you hear and
everyone was like what
they were like beyonce made a new album
and you're like really and they're like
yeah and it has a video
and jay-z cheated i guess you're like oh
my god so much so much news here
right so many news is going on with with
[ __ ] kanye
and er with jay-z and beyonce and [ __ ]
like that
but i don't like how kanye's like we're
gonna have a
we're gonna have the [ __ ]
thing we're gonna have the album come
out
and it's gonna come out in a week and in
a week we're like here we go and he's
like psych two weeks two and we're like
two weeks from now and he's like maybe
yup and we're like cool and then we get
there and he's like uh you know what who
knows but
look what i'm wearing
and i'm just like can you just i now i
gotta listen i don't the last kanye
album which was the one where the
[ __ ] was all about the gospel [ __ ]
was that the last one oh man that [ __ ]
was just like
one time my friend said he was a huge
dave matthews fan this is when i was in
high school he's a huge dave matthews
fan huge dave matthews fan that [ __ ]
song came out it was from that album
that would go
that song you know
he loved that song he couldn't dude he
would roll up in his [ __ ] jeep
wrangler to my house pick me up and go
to george's and just plank
plank plank plank balloon needle plank
plank plank playing heaven there's a low
[Laughter]
that big ass
jacked [ __ ] on the violin
that big jacked dude in the dave
matthews band with the violin that you
know that wasn't even violin that was a
full bass he was just that big
just putting it on his shoulder like
it's a cellular phone
plank
plank plank plank
that guy died at like 42 because he was
just too big and jacked
and uh the doctor came in and he was
like i'm sorry but your husband passed
away and the wife was like why and he
said
to jacked
and over the [ __ ]
doctors over the waiting room music it
was playing
playing playing
and my buddy loved that song
and uh then the new dave val dave
matthews album came out
and he didn't like it
and i was like
hey you like that dave matthews album
that came out and he was like dude no
but you know what i think and i was like
here we go
because i didn't like any dave matthews
and not that he's not talented he is
dude that's a satellite
[Music]
it's probably good you know if you wear
sandals you love that song you know what
i'm talking about if you wear
button-down short sleeve shirts and
shorts
and sandals
and that song comes on you jizz that's
period that's it you jizz
so if i [ __ ] if that song comes on if
a guy's in
literally
birkenstock [ __ ] forget it dude if you
even
the second you put on your birkenstocks
the second that toe enters a birkenstock
right one of your toes just one you
might not even know where another one is
but you find one and you go to pick it
up
and you hear plain
plant plant plant the immediate like a
little bit of jizz just you know what i
mean
it has to be
you can hear if you're a white guy with
like a side part and a button down with
cargo shorts
you can hear plank play play playing and
not go jizz and you can also wear
birkenstocks and knuckle jizz but the
second you get your foot close to a
birkenstock and you got all that apparel
on and you hear playing then immediate
side jizz right
immediate hip jizz okay
so my buddy was saying to me
um
yeah you know what i think i said what
he said i think he purposely made an
album that was so bad to see if his fans
would still
like it and pretend that it was good
and i just go like this
oh but
people don't do that
playing
playing playing playing we have a silly
goose time and we have a good time right
and that's what we do that's what we do
i don't uh so when the [ __ ] is kanye
coming out with this album mostly i
don't care but mostly i'm just like i
want people on the internet to shut the
[ __ ] up about it because when people
come when people first of all i'm i'm
off the internet the only thing i have
is instagram and tiktok and uh youtube
so that's a lot of the things but
uh
the thing is
you don't
i don't i don't
like
cycle out
you know
hey news
cycle it out
kanye west comes on oh when's his album
dropping oh who knows what's up every uh
oh but we don't know and i follow a lot
of sneaker pages it's always a sneaker
page donda's going to drop what are you
going to be wearing when don does draw
it's like all right dude don't try to be
a part of it you're just a sneaker page
but like
i wanted to cause that's what happens
dude it's the lead up to the [ __ ] and
maybe this is what kanye knows but it's
always the lead up to the [ __ ] that gets
the [ __ ] and then when the [ __ ] happens
five days later it's gone dude it's gone
like all these movies come out like
remember the [ __ ] war after tomorrow
or whatever the [ __ ] that chris
pratt movie is
it was like you couldn't go you couldn't
turn left on a street without seeing a
billboard
you'd put on your sunglasses and there'd
be an ad in on the inside of your lenses
and the second that movie came out
everyone was just like okay we're done
talking about this nobody's gonna
[ __ ] talk about this anymore you
understand me
it was all about the lead up we don't
give a [ __ ] about it anymore
so i can't wait for it to come out and
for him to say some crazy ass [ __ ] when
it comes out and then have it be over
dude
remember when he was just screaming
about how he almost killed his kids or
whatever the [ __ ] it was like jesus
christ man hey go get help you know i
mean i'm no doctor but go get help but
i'm no doctor but go get help you know
go get help if you're screaming about
that mostly go get help if you're
streaming about anything too much if
you're screaming a lot if you stream
more than once a day go get help
i saw the dude i was at the [ __ ]
coffee bee coffee bean and tea leaf
today i was on twitch i was do i was
twitching which is how i call it dude
and i know people are like you sold
that's not what they call it dude i'm
old how about this i'm old so i know
okay how about that how about it's
twitching now how about that
how about that
no it's not because why
cause why cause [ __ ]
what's his name jim merk is out there
[ __ ] with his goddamn
uh
camera only showing one eye just like
this
jimmy murks
just like this
playing [ __ ] war zone
go go back back back go
where are you
found it
go you have it
go go i got it
back back back up back up [ __ ] [ __ ] okay
okay
god damn it
go this is everybody on twitch go go go
you got it
go
go go you got it
you got it good you got it
i got it i got it i got it i got it i
got it i got it go go go go go i got it
i got it i got it go go i got it okay
you have it
[ __ ] [ __ ]
we got it here we go see i think it's
the the it's the weapon that go go go go
and always falling into the from the air
you know what i mean the hands are out
like this
what's that is that the game war zone
where you're falling into the [ __ ]
and just the hands are out and then and
then some guy
jimmy murks go go i got it okay cut the
cord got it good go go
because he [ __ ] responds in the same
area see that's the thing he responds in
the same area and and and nine million
people are watching it
judoon
so i was on twitch twitching i was
twitching in my car like a [ __ ] heron
addict like a meth
subscriber
and um
i was talking and [ __ ] cause you're boys
on twitch now come on down to flex
avenue and drive with us
if you're on my twitch
you live on flex avenue that's it that's
that's what it is dude
you don't have to subscribe or whatever
the [ __ ] if you do thank you but fine if
you don't if you're watching this is
flex avenue where we going let's see
let's leave it open let's leave it open
ended right there's no destination
because why because it's about the
journey when you're on my twitch
and uh so i am on
doing this
and as i'm doing this i see
um
this guy
who i put on tick tock
that was outside the tower records doing
the karaoke
of wangsta right
and i put it on tick tock and go on my
tic toc you see this guy doing karaoke
of wang stuff first of all the worst
music to do karaoke on
is is rap music you know you might as
well do a [ __ ] song from diplo it did
just like
just like up there with a [ __ ]
microphone just
like
hip-hop is just people always think
they're going to be the funny guy the
least funny guy does the hip-hop song
in like a karaoke bar
the guy's like oh dude you want me to do
it all right cool all right [ __ ] it i'll
do it i'll do it i'll do a song uh do
you have um
uh miami from will smith
and he's up there and he's just like
bienvenido on me emmy and you're just
like dude it's not funny bro
do heart
do heart sing heart sing a heart song
how do i get you alone
and that's just without me [ __ ]
warming up dude
how do i get you alone
that's me a little warmer so you could
imagine if i do some mayo mayo mayo may
and
right if i do some of those vocal
exercises first and then i'm just like
how do i get
you alone
it's already exponentially better all
right
sing heart dude you really want to come
to play sing a heart don't be all that
[ __ ] jiggy with it [ __ ]
or jump by crisscross that song was hot
like one march of 1989.
chris cross still make a joke because
the guy who thinks he's going to be
funny doing rap or hip-hop and karaoke
is always so out of breath and birthing
nodes
like the first verse
chris costa make it jump jump that's
that'll make you jump jump just also
make a jump jump and then they're just
like they sound like a car dying
not trying to compare it while doing
another game because they're going very
good the daddy i may see yeah you know
me
then make a hustle and bustling but
moving all around gee just some guy with
a [ __ ] huge pit stains and a
button-down blue shirt with [ __ ]
birkenstocks on just they didn't have
any dave matthews
plus i don't know i don't know
the ball doesn't bounce over the plank
plank plank plank so i never knew when
they come
those aren't words you don't have to
whatever dude
so um
so yeah so i don't even know what i was
devolving and talking about with the
[ __ ] crisscross and the and the
donda i think i was talking about donda
but i don't remember where i went to but
sometimes that's what happens in this
podcast man we just fly by the seat of
our pants we get off oh twitch that's
what it is twitch and he's back dude
and he's [ __ ] back like that dude
he's freaking back man
um
yeah so i saw this guy
uh who was
karaoke
wangsta over in the tower records
parking lots with which by the way
there's still a tower records on sunset
boulevard
boulevard hey get rid of it hey make a
hotel hey have a kinkos there hey
whatever it is
it's not historical i don't care it's an
empty building with a [ __ ] let with
some letters painted on it it's just i
posted it up you're like where's there's
still a tower of records oh my god when
was this video taken
it's just get rid of it all right
i yeah i i okay fine what who played the
smith's there played played once outside
the parking lot and so now you can't
[ __ ] build on anything it's a
historic landmark no it's not it's just
a tower records
and uh so anyway he was at this [ __ ]
coffee bean and he was like you know he
and i i roll in and there this dude is
with a [ __ ] amp on the back of his i
don't know how he has it but a porsche
cayenne
and this amp this is it jbl speakers
with a [ __ ] microphone
attached to it
and he's [ __ ] rapping for sunset
boulevard
i can't remember what song he was doing
but he was killing it and i drove by
and i rolled down the window and i said
hey man what's up
and he was like oh you like it and i was
like hell yeah bro
and i got him on my twitch a little bit
i didn't show him because i didn't ask
him because also it seemed like he had
like [ __ ] you know what i mean
darkness in his soul but
i didn't want him to [ __ ] stab me
and uh
and we were just and and so we talked a
little bit on my twitch and then i i got
the coffee and i got the [ __ ] out of
there before people showed up because i
don't want to get [ __ ] sniped on
twitch you know
because i dox myself no matter where i
am on twitch [ __ ] it what am i going to
do
what what am i going to do keep it here
who am my jimmy marks just keeping it
right here
go go back up back up [ __ ]
all right where is it you got it i got
it
um
so yeah
we got that merch out now
uh we restocked to be more memorable
[ __ ] and the [ __ ] bangs you saw the last
episode on my podcast i wore with the
dmx chain to show you guys a little bit
of high fashion
but you can go to crystallia.com cop
that [ __ ] or you can cop the go medium
and sometimes stay out [ __ ] and hit the
gym
because [ __ ] going harder going home go
medium and sometimes stay out and that's
it and it brings a real ladies vibe out
you know what that's what i'm about i'm
about a real ladies vibe
but anyway what i was talking about
donda before i got sidetracked and all
the other [ __ ] i was talking about is
this kanye fan i read
is going on a hunger strike until donda
is out
hey
gun die
let's listen to this i haven't even
listened to it yet honestly
this message goes out to kanye west
himself
wow so fill in himself that he said
himself afterwards you never need to say
himself
just say kanye west
also he won't hear it
this message goes out to kanye west
himself
plain edge football he has a plain edge
football shirt on and it's backwards
he didn't even do the thing where he
[ __ ] made it go right side
this message goes out to kanye west
himself uh sir the guy who sits on the
end of the bar in cheers
what's that guy's name
no way night way night right
wayne knight isn't that his name
george wendt george went
oh yeah who's wayne knight
did i make up a guy
oh that's the other guy that looks just
like him in seinfeld
all right cool george went yeah george
went
where the [ __ ] did george went go george
went that's where he went got it what a
[ __ ] stupid joke but it i made it up
in real time so anyway
patrick wooden will go on a hunger
strike
oh here we go gonna start it over
here this message goes out to kanye west
himself
i patrick wooden will go on a hunger
strike till donde is released on all
platforms i'm sick of waiting i will not
eat another bite of food till i see
dondo on all platforms i got like i got
like a week before i die
dropped on to now kanyang
please
cute
i actually thought he was cute please
when he said please thought he was
[ __ ] 38 till he said please like that
then i realized that he was 12. um
i john o'connor he's got [ __ ] doritos
and cheetos
george went um
this guy's gonna die because connie's
not gonna
anyway
uh
this is crazy this guy [ __ ] i see
this other thing tory lane
tory lane's nft album sold a million in
less than a minute bro
didn't he shoot somebody's [ __ ] foot
off i don't know i don't even know you
know megan the stallion
he shot her foot off
and then he's people and then he's just
like
[ __ ] it
i rap i'll i'll still rap and people are
like
you know
you know what i mean
the world's so backwards
um
speaking of which this guy [ __ ] on uh
i found this guy who uh he kind of went
viral but he was like putting up uh he
went to go sell his shoe
this lady has been having miscarriages
with uh um in this uh in a relationship
she had like seven or eight
it's really sad
and this guy sold his shoe half of his
shoe collection
to pay for the ivf ivf is really
expensive it's like 20 grand with the
medication and everything like that
and uh it didn't take
and
so
he went to go sell the rest of his shoes
and his wife just thought it was to flip
him because it was a good time to sell
him and he said no i did this for the
ivf again and it's not even a chance
there's not even like there's a chance
it could not work i mean she's it hadn't
it hasn't worked before for this guy
this guy [ __ ] um
yeah he uh he actually um
sold his like the rest of his shoe
collection which is like you know it's
hard to part with but worth it if it
works and even if it doesn't it's you
know it's like you're still doing the
right thing but
it went viral and uh i uh
i sent him money to buy shoes because
that [ __ ] touched my heart
um
who is this guy actually let me find
this guy actually i have it in my phone
i think
um
it's like uh
let me see if i can find this guy
whoa
here it is ej win
ej win ejw underscore zero three
i was touched by his story man there's
good [ __ ] out there sometimes it feels
like the world's just [ __ ] crumbling
you know but then you see something like
that and it just [ __ ] feels good and
it touches your heart it touches your
heart strings
you know it touches your [ __ ] heart
strings
always good in the middle of my podcast
when i look at my phone and i see it has
900 text messages and then i have a
[ __ ] huge anxiety spike um oh is it
oh is anybody dead oh no people are just
bullshitting on a text on a group text
okay cool um
oh [ __ ] somebody must be on fire oh no
oh it's just the [ __ ] comedians in
the group chain that tested texted 155
times okay great
imagine that's how you died the [ __ ]
you you didn't eat because kanye didn't
put out because some guy didn't put out
now what a boil all balls down to akane
is just some guy you know
yeah you get up to heaven what the [ __ ]
happened yeah i didn't eat why again
there's so many people in the world i
can't keep track i didn't eat because
some kanye west uh did put out who's
kanye west oh he's a guy that he's a
really famous artist is just some guy
well i guess to you yeah if you're jesus
christ he just so you you didn't eat
because some guy didn't put out uh music
yeah oh you're going to hell
you wasted your life going to hell
um
oh we cut we had to cut because we made
a [ __ ] mistake dude the guy who died
in the dave matthews band was not the
big violinist it was the [ __ ] other
dude who does the saxophone leroy moore
and he is also black and i'm racist
amazing dude i just mixed up two black
dudes that were in the same group i'm
racist
[ __ ] me dude don't like that i made that
mistake
they're all so talented dude though dude
the one dude's like playing play wait a
minute was this the guy that did the
plank
was leroy moore the guy who goes blank
he was the guy because he does that's a
sax maybe that's is that a sax
play let's just pretend it is so we can
oh man that's
the guy who invented the plank is gone
dude
that's sad dude
you know
wow
how about this is another thing we found
out
while we cut
because one fire was like dude the other
guy died and i was like oh my god one
higher i guess but i'm on fire because
you interrupted the show
uh
about this [ __ ]
this was unreal dude they sent me this
dave matthews band chicago river
incident
on august 8 2004 over the kinsey street
bridge in chicago illinois
a tour bus belonging to the dave
matthews band
dumped an estimated 800 pounds of human
waste
from the bus's septic tank
onto a passenger sightseeing boat on the
chicago river below
plank
plank plank plank
imagine just that was just imagine that
was what the boat was playing
and they were just like oh i loved guys
with birkenstocks just oh i love
white dudes with [ __ ] side parts and
button down short sleeve shirts with
cargo shorts just drinking [ __ ]
just beers you know what i mean just
[ __ ] a white as [ __ ] beer
just plank
plank plank plank just do like oh just
looking up getting some catching some
brace and 800 pounds
of
violinist [ __ ] just drops into your
mouth dude and in your eyes
how do you have a hey
how do you have a hundred pounds of [ __ ]
how many pounds is a one [ __ ]
three
say eat a big meal
a big meal
how many pounds of [ __ ] is that
two and a half
they stored it up where
where the [ __ ] they just stored it under
the bus 800 pounds of [ __ ] you know it
was the big ass [ __ ] jack
violinist that was half of his
three shits
he would come out just like hey man i
really destroyed that i really destroyed
the back of the bus man we better empty
this out
and dave matthews was just like yeah
we'll do in a second man just puffing
weed we'll do it in a second don't even
worry about it there's a bridge coming
up in chicago
are you sure man i let out three shits
and i swear they were all together
500 pounds
just in his big ass purple
you know what i mean just with a big
bait you couldn't tell a big base on his
[ __ ] shoulder like a violin all right
man if that's what you say
and dave matthews just like yeah man i
got it all covered i talked to the bus
driver you know satellites
[Music]
[Laughter]
just that big ass violinist just caved
over on one of the [ __ ] on the inside
of the bu you look at the outside of the
bus the bus is just like this driving
along the way and when he shits it evens
it out for a little bit and then he
caves again
and sits down
hey man and dave matthews doesn't even
give a [ __ ] that the bus is on just two
like one side of wheels dave matthews is
just high off wheat he's not even eating
brownies he's just like eating weed out
of the bag
hey man you want to sit on the other
side or whatever i don't care man
holy on rice frozen glories and a frozen
rose no rice
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] saxophone players having a heart
attack no one even knows
and then [ __ ]
hey man we're coming up on that bridge
you wanna he makes [ __ ]
leroy drive hey leroy you wanna [ __ ]
you wanna hit the hatch man
let all the [ __ ] out
[ __ ] what's his name that that big
guy who does the who plays the bass
violin i forget his name man but he
wears [ __ ] like lucky charms hats
that guy over there
that guy said he [ __ ] 500 pounds i doubt
it man
night rolling on dubs and saving those
so
yeah dude let that [ __ ] out man
satellite rolling on dubs and rolling
dubs doing the rock away
and uh
just everyone's losing their mind
and then [ __ ] hey you wanna make
another song with the [ __ ] plank
sound and um
they let it go let's [ __ ] them up man go
ahead and then
boom and then
you hear
like [ __ ] people like they got hit
with napalm just oh my god
is this violinist [ __ ]
and they look and they just don't give a
[ __ ] and then they got
the resulting controversy i love
controversy that involves [ __ ] dude
you know
is it a controversy
led to more than 300 000 in settlements
donations and fines the band's bus
driver steve steve
stefan or stephen wall pleaded guilty to
dumping the waste in march 2005.
wow dude dave massa would you say it's
not my fault man you're the one who
[ __ ] dumped the waste on all those
white people
this is crazy
the band booked five buses for its show
accused bus driver stephen wool
drove the bus of dave matthews banned
violinist
[Laughter]
it was him dude it was the violinist
dude i'm [ __ ] you not it was the
violinist boyd tinsley dude
magical name
seven foot six boyd tinsley
never wearing a shirt always wearing the
lucky charms hat
shits 90 pounds each time no matter what
he eats even if he doesn't eat anything
um
wow dude it was his bus
oh my god
imagine that's your bus
hey sir why do you have hi this is the
[ __ ] chicago tribune news why the
[ __ ] did you why do you have 800 pounds
of [ __ ]
playing
playing playing playing [ __ ] hit it
leroy blink they just walk
because the bus is now [ __ ] a crime
scene just hit it walk to the venue
dude wow
[ __ ] that [ __ ] song
you know what i mean just in the grass
feeling the earth
with [ __ ] puka shells on
um
just took a piss break got to some type
take sometimes take peepee breaks who am
i calvin just pissing in the diaper no
way dude
he's so cute dude he starts telling he
told us when he goes poopo he goes in
the corner and he and he goes poopoo and
his eyes water and he goes in the corner
and does poo-poo by himself like it's a
toilet and then he comes to us walks
back out and says
cute
so cute um so yeah so that's what's up
um
i found this thing actually and i want
to know uh what the whole deal is with
this because this is amazing and i've
never heard it before
[ __ ] uber let me start out by just being
like this [ __ ] uber
[ __ ] lyft
this is where it's at dude
taxi dave
i don't care
how much it is
or where i am
calling him for a ride i don't know
where he is but he's taking me if i ever
need to i drive dude i'm the guy that
drives you understand i don't drink
and also i never know when i need to
hightail it out of a place where people
take ubers i'm like you're crazy what if
some [ __ ] goes down what are you gonna
do run into an alley [ __ ] that dude i'm
in my car
zipping away
i got a buddy who only takes ubers and
it's just like dude
you're just gonna sit in the back of
someone's ultima
no
by the way i saw a guy today who was
driving a car a button on my instagram
stories and he bungee co the car the
door his driver's door wouldn't shut and
then he bungee corded it together and as
he was driving the door was like
swinging open it was flapping a wing
and i was like ah so dangerous
um so this is it taxi dave dude
sacramento i guess is where it is hi i'm
taxi dave a self-employed yellow cab
driver in downtown sacramento california
so far going fine a little bit weird
that he's completely miked up in one of
the [ __ ] bill bellamy
uh booty call mics when he when he made
the booty call
uh joke when he created that
term or a [ __ ] britney spears with
the snake on his on her shoulder he's
got one of those mics that come around
front from his ear
i want to invite you to come visit
sacramento uh california i didn't know
where he was so insecure had to download
the rest of the location sacramento uh
[Music]
you've got mail
he's got dialogue sacramento
so insecure how he said it do it
sacramento
california because uh we've been added
new bars nightclubs hotels restaurants
and there's a lot of tourism with the
state capital
museum let me just say god bless this
guy you know what i'm talking about he's
going the extra mile this is what i
don't understand with [ __ ] who
won't do the work bro you know how much
i think about comedy and think about
jokes and do [ __ ] and want to do
funny [ __ ] and like try to make people
laugh it's always it's all the time okay
yeah i took a year off but always
and it's just like
this guy is a taxi driver and he's like
well then let's get business
and he's not thinking small like let's
try to drive the people around to
sacramento he's thinking like
like coca-cola this motherfucker's like
let's get more people in this place
so we can drive those around
let's have a surplus of people so he
makes a youtube video gets a britney mic
and [ __ ] goes out and makes a youtube
commercial about his thing saying hey
we've got a lot more bars in sacramento
come on down internet
like art
history and transportation i mean he's
lying at this point art and history
in sacramento like it's the sistine
chapel
it's sacramento
it's the oops capital it's one of those
oops capitals you know what i'm talking
about
it should be la
the capital of calif of california it
should be la all right
all right oh the capital of new york
is
oh it's albany
isn't it
oops
you ever been to albany the answer
is probably no
but i have because your boy
makes the usa map look like a bunch of
zits
you understand
i take those thumb those those red
thumbtacks i'm sticking them everywhere
your boy makes the usa your boy does so
much
traveling then he makes the usa
look like a crater-faced teen
all right
i look like the map of where
the feds are trying to find the serial
killer now that's just how i make the
map look with my travelogue
all right
it's one of those oops capitals
[ __ ] albany my ass it's new york
manhattan's the capital of [ __ ] new
york
yeah but actually because way back when
it's funny because you say that because
way back when the settlers it always has
to do with settlers shut the [ __ ] up you
know
you tell me any state i'll tell you the
capital it doesn't matter if it's
capital or not [ __ ] uh uh
pennsylvania
philadelphia i don't know if it's it or
not but it is it is what is it uh um
pittsburgh
[ __ ]
harrisburg [ __ ] out of here dude
harrisburg
even i haven't been a [ __ ] harrisburg
florida it's miami i don't give a [ __ ]
what you say that's what it is that's
where everybody goes to sit up that's
the capital
all right
oregon portland
montana who knows the whole thing's a
capital i don't even know a [ __ ]
place there montana for [ __ ] sake
this guy's killing it dude
now sacramento is definitely the place
to be
for tourism fine dining and just plain
partying
now when you come down this record
call me taxi dave and my party cab
and you can find all oh they cut they
cut in the middle of a sentence dude
when you cut in the middle of a sentence
and you're obviously using a vhs
camcorder you rip
you're the best
information about me on my website at
sac taxidave.com
check it out oh paused for too long
wasn't a cut yeah oh no huh you know who
i am i'm taxi dave taxi dave and my
black and yellow black and yellow cab
yeah uh huh you know who i am i'm taxi
dave taxi dave in my black and yellow
black and
a [ __ ] didn't hit it tried to touch the
cab missed it oh dude
you know
this is amazing dude
sack taxi dave
yeah uh-huh somebody you know who i am
and everything i do i do is big
everything i do i do is big dude
whenever he goes yeah he goes like this
yeah and bends down
swipe
now my cab looks unapproachable
it's safe because it's mean and it's
super clean
and you want to ride with me because i'm
the big cat
i'll be behind the wheel of my yellow
cab singing it and slapping it and
that's that oh
i'll be behind the wheel of my yellow
cab singing it and snapping it and
that's that snap in it dude
i'll be snapping it wait who's the
driver who's taxi dude he's the guy
who's behind the wheel and snaps it
what
dude this guy's unreal
wow dude he only wraps one bar and then
cuts and thinks of another bar and then
does that bar and then cuts after every
bar
yeah
uh-huh you know who i am yeah what would
we do taxi dave taxi dave in my yellow
cab yellow cab cincy right yeah yeah
you know who i am i'm taxi dave taxi
dave in my black and yellow black and
yellow cab yeah
i got a call from a customer this just
in
they need a pickup at the holiday inn
gotta go now but when you're in sac town
give me a call because i'll be your best
ride ever in downtown sacramento
didn't rhyme
give me rhymed call with sacramento like
he's eminem
orange and orange
sacramento call even eminem couldn't do
that
what if you drove away and crashed
uh-huh you know who i am
wow dude then they played [ __ ] wiz
khalifa
thanks for listening to congratulations
and you know what you got to go out and
i didn't say it i saved it for the end
dude but [ __ ] cough on that subscribe
button dude
vomit on that like button
and just [ __ ] [ __ ] blood all over
that bell notification
seriously man
but really do it
hey guys that's the episode to catch the
rest of the episode uh you can go over
to my patreon which is
patreon.comcrystalia
you got the rest of this episode and you
get all of the full episodes of
congratulations which you haven't heard
yet if you're not on patreon and there
are also there's one extra episode a
month and you can watch all of the past
extra episodes a month if you sign up
for patreon right now and there's also a
new segment that i do um that's too
too deep called review mode so uh we got
patreon exclusives we got behind the
scenes we got everything so
patreon.com go sign up thanks a lot guys
[Music]
congratulations
thank you
[Music]
welcome to the next episode of collage
nope nope nope that wasn't a good one